you know every single thing that you
think you you need you'll have it
yeah there's not a single thing that you
won't have by going to the academy in
terms of the actual
theory side and understanding how it's
done yeah in terms of actually
understanding how to grow the business
how to make money from your company
how you need to do it all the compliance
stages that you need to do it all is
kind of given to you
there and it really just up to you to
kind of listen and do it i mean there's
so many other people in the room so you
know you can always say you know how
come everyone else doesn't get
successful when it's just to implement
what's been said to be honest with you
because it's all
given to you yeah at that extent and the
academy you mentioned two days
yep because normally a training program
is two days
but then you go on lots and lots of
different training programs and yourself
mentoring and everything like that
so okay so you go through the training
walk me through your first
deal okay um i'll talk you from my first
deal
from my main investor and i'll get to
how i got to if you if you want to get
to that stage so
um after i went to the academy after i i
went to the crash course
i set off my own company um i set my
company up and i started you know i made
the website
i put a little bit of money in in the
business i thought to myself well you
know i've made a promise to my father
this is what i'm going to be doing this
i'm going to be paying off so i'm going
to fill out to do that
um i did kind of you know do a little
bit of code deal sourcing and then did a
little information understanding myself
and then a little bit further down they
got to the state of around coronavirus
time
where one of my main deals had actually
fallen through at that time and it was
kind of a bit
at the time where i thought okay because
of this lockdown thing property may be
taking a little bit of a stop obviously
i was watching the videos and you know
things were saying otherwise but
to myself i got kind of dragged into
forex and
trading where you know i worked for
actually a company to do trading for a
couple bit for a little bit of time
and afterwards uh the actual owner of
the company this year he put me in and
he said
i know you've been doing property i know
you've tried to set up a property
business and this was all for me
basically talking about what i was doing
beforehand to him and he said well what
i want to do is i want to make some
money from property and
i know you've had training and he
literally said i know you've gone to
gone and done the training i know you've
experienced from this stuff
so would you want to help me out with
this and do you want to work together to
do this
of course yes and you know what can i
just stop you right there though because
that is really important number one when
you invest in yourself
yes then people want to invest in
definitely 100
there's no i would have never been given
this opportunity if i hadn't joined an
academy and i'm saying necessarily you
have to join
an academy tours but 1 000 it's the fact
that they know what this guy has the
knowledge
i don't have that knowledge or whatever
that knowledge is so
and it's not rookie it's not knowledge
picked up from bits and bobs and
a youtube video here and a mentor here
and a person and dave the pub
and the it's like no i've got the
straightforward
abc xyz yeah so you had the knowledge
you had the reputation to be able to say
i've got the knowledge
you were worried that's funny that is
because you're on the academy and
everything and then we went to lockdown
i was saying on youtube
yeah i was doing financial freedom
challenges from my house in london yes
yes
and you were like i'll tell you the
reason being to it because i wasn't very
much of a
sort of online thing i tried to do
advertising on facebook and stuff i sat
down and tried yeah
but for me it just i understand i just
thought was it when they closed down the
property market
it was you just thought forget this i
thought to myself well okay um
oil's falling the currencies commodities
are overfalling there's bitcoin
there's a lot of money to be made and
everyone talked about you know they're
waiting for this time i had to blow
money saved up as well
you know i had money to owe to my father
as well about time but i thought to
myself well
i could put a little bit of money in
there which was a mistake on my behalf
to my father
um i put a little bit of money on on on
the trading side and how did it go
it didn't go very well in terms of the
oil market i didn't make money on
everything else but
it was a heavy hit on on when right and
the oil fell but you wanted to you
wanted to
you were just the the whole property
market was locked down yeah so you
thought you'd donate for a little bit i
put on a pause
i thought who was head of the
forex company was like actually i want
to do a property yeah because i had
i'd explained in the process before i
had obviously talked to him and we have
a very good relationship and
and you know i told him it's as easy as
this to make money you know you just
you know that you can buy a house like
that you know you just cost this
everything it's the build process
and if you find the right house you can
sell it from for more yeah it's all
about adding the value to the property
for example in terms of actually the
flipping side
and you know he understood what i was
trying to say he understood the whole
process and he answered it very well
this gentleman is a very very smart and
very very successful businessman himself
you know more than other ones close but
a couple hundred million
just for himself and his position and he
he he said to me
ali i want to do this i now need you to
if you're interested in helping me out
go and find out where's the best area
for me to invest that will give me the
most
so you know it took me you know a couple
weeks to research that area that area
that i had to find my patch which is
obviously what you did teach at that
time as well so
i looked at how much the property
market's fallen in that area how much
it's risen
all together how much it does rise in
that area so a lot of research into find
deciding to my area
where's the best place for us to invest
online can you reveal what what your
patch is yep micro village
sheffield rover doncaster sheffield
rotherham doncaster
why did you choose that patch so i chose
that patch and basis of okay there's one
thing this is from the academy as well
and
i'll give it a bit so it's in terms of
ratio wise as well which was the biggest
factor for me
in terms of houses on the market and how
many houses on the market have been sold
so you know that every house support
market about three or four houses gets
sold
yeah and sheffield and doncaster one of
the best ratios from my side you know
a house will come it will go and that
wasn't even during the whole
sort of property sort of boom and
everything it was very very good at that
time
you know it had fallen a decent amount
it was sort of everything had been
placed
and we could see good good good years of
growth and we knew that you know we
could make good money from that area we
knew that
there was train lines coming you know we
did all of our you know i did all of my
research and so really really
that this place could give a really
really good boom and could make you know
that's a brilliant point and to get that
especially if you're looking at flipping
or brr like you've done yeah but it is
you just have to look how many houses
are for sale in the whole of sheffield
include houses sold and then not include
houses sold and you can see the right
you can see
exactly exactly and if it says if it
says there's a thousand houses for sale
oh and including houses for sold there's
a thousand and fifty you think oh houses
aren't selling very well there yeah
if it says including houses that have
sold there's three thousand yeah
well well that means that they're right
and they're all subject to contracting
the sort of five or six months so you
know to yourself well
these houses are going and they're going
well if you get a good house in the
market that's
good location exactly what the buyers
are looking for with a good either
return or a good you know appealing to a
first time buyer
there'll be no problem